hello and welcome to maths amplified in
this video we are going to learn about
the simple interrupted sutures
interrupted sutures are the most
commonly used technique in the closure
of skin it is known as interrupted
because the individual stitches aren't
connected they are separate and if one
suture fails the others hold the wound
in place it is a simple technique and
relatively easy to place by beginners
this is the third video in the suturing
technique for beginners video series
brought to you by med simplified in
collaboration with kids of medicine we
will be using this suturing practice
gate to learn about these techniques
which was sent to me by kids of medicine
this skit is excellent for beginners and
contains all the things that you need to
begin learning about suturing check the
link below in the description and use
the coupon code med 10 to get a 10%
discount on this kit okay so let's begin
with the technique of simple interrupted
sutures to begin the first step is to
load the suture material and your needle
in the needle holder you hold the needle
at the junction of the distal 2/3 and
the proximal 1/3 of the needle this
imparts the ability to the needle and
your movements after loading the needle
lock the needle holder so that your
needle remains fixed and stable to start
suturing the first step is to gently
lift the skin with the forceps this
allows you to visualize the wound and
the skin properly and plan your entry
and exit points exactly pierce the skin
surface with a needle at a 90 degree
angle to the skin the needle should not
be tilted as it may lead to a more
superficial or deeper entry into the
wound
keeping the needle at a perpendicular
angle allows your movements to be
precise and accurate
the entry point should be four
millimeters from the wound edge the next
step is to pass the needle through one
side of the skin of the wound and make
it rise out of the middle of the wound
to do this you have to use a curved
motion of your wrist that allows the
curved needle to easily pass through the
skin as the needle rises out in the
middle of the wound use your forceps to
hold your needle as you release your
needle holder grab the needle again with
your needle holder the next part
consists of passing the needle in a
similar style of motion through the
opposite edge of the wound
to do this we again lift the opposing
skin edge gently with the forceps to
visualize the wound properly we pierce
the skin in the middle of the wound and
using the same curved motion of our
wrist the needle travels perpendicularly
through the dermis from inside to
outside
we use the forceps to grasp the needle
and stabilize it until we hold the
needle again without needle holder
using your needle holder pull the suture
material through the wound leaving a
three to four centimeter tail behind for
the final part of tying the knot
to tie the knot you grasp the needle
holder in one hand and the suture in
your other hand the first step is to
make two loops of the suture material
around your needle holder then grasp the
tail end of the suture material with
your needle holder and pass it in
between those two loops of suture that
you just made this is your first knot
move you're not at this side of the
wound so that it doesn't lay directly
over the wound after this make one more
loop of the suture thread around the
needle holder again grasp the tail end
of the suture and pull it through the
loop that you just made this second knot
imparts stability to the sutures and
ensures that the knot won't open up
spontaneously now depending upon the
conditions of the wound and how much
strength you want in your sutures you
can place one to two more of these
single loop knots over your first knot
pull both ends of the suture with your
needle holder and trim the suture to one
to two centimeters length it is
important not to trim the sutures to a
very short length as it makes removing
those sutures very difficult after a few
days
you can also check out the met
simplified suturing PDF guide which
helps you to learn suturing in a better
way a clear and concise guide that
includes step-by-step learning of
various techniques in a simple and easy
to understand presentation keep it in
your phone and follow along as you
practice you can get this copy by
joining meThe simplifies community on
patreon.com plus you will also unlock
many other cool features like flashcards
from all other videos members exclusive
content and much more thank you so much
for watching guys see you in the next
video